and dad once said to me tragedy has a
way of finding people
Ripple's some people till they curl up
into a ball
oh my god what have I done
let mr. Kennedy chose to carry death she
asked of a mammal the influence what the
hell happened teddy
[Music]
it was an accident
I was driving
story like this could dominate the
headlines for weeks chief we got a body
that body holds a lot of Secrets suppose
can be the difference between guilt and
innocence so we need to be in control of
them there's not a lot of senators that
are charged with manslaughter that go on
to become present what do we do to help
the senator
we tell the truth
or at least our version been diagnosed
with concussion I haven't examined the
patient yet these theatrics are not
gonna hold up in a court of law
how are you guys I'm not going to be the
one defined by my flaws if her family
doesn't blame you
why should America I want to be a great
man I just don't know who I am
[Music]
his family first appears we have a true
compass and we follow three
Lois's had a temper Peter betrayed Jesus
I have Chappaquiddick Moses had a temper
but he never left a girl at the bottom
of the Red Sea
[Music]
you